I am your father's brothers nephews
cousins former roommate alright gotta
talk a little bit more about Sherlock
and now I'm going to talk about what I
kind of only brushed the surface of when
I talked about the episode The Lying
detective and that is euros secret
sister for Sherlock Holmes now this one
is interesting because it's the first
major villain that they've had who has
no precedent in the books obviously up
to this point we've had Moriarty we've
had Irene Adler we've had Magnussen even
coverton Smith is actually a you know a
villain a one-time villain from a story
so this whole thing this is completely
new territory and as much as I really
like the execution of the reveal and I'm
really liking the performance from this
actress I'm really nervous about whether
or not they can stick the landing on
this here's the main reason why I'm
nervous it's always risky for any show
or movie or anything to introduce a
character that we haven't seen up to
this point and do some sort of they were
behind the scenes pulling the strings
the whole type thing because it tends to
at best stretch credibility and at worst
just be impossible to buy I think a
recent example that completely fell on
its face was the reveal of Blofeld
inspector that oh man that didn't work I
already did a video on that if you want
to hear my full ran there I won't do it
here but needless to say I'm not
inherently opposed at the whole sort of
secret nemesis you know undermining them
covertly and all that I'm not inherently
opposed to it it's just way too often
stories shows movies they just they
overplay that hand and I'm really
worried that's gonna happen here and
part laries I'm really worried about
that is Moriarty we still have not
picked up on the Moriarty thread that
was left and there's only one episode
left which means that whatever we're
getting has to not only explain and
resolve euros it also has to resolve
Moriarty and I'm a
that by forcing the two to either share
space or more than likely integrate them
so that they feed into each other that
ultimately this is going to undermine
Moriarty in some way like we're gonna
find out euros was working alongside
Moriarty that whole time or that the
whole did you miss me thing was never
Moriarty himself and it was just euros
getting Sherlock's attention and that
Moriarty's the whole thing basically
ended when he shot himself through the
head and either of those sorts of
scenarios
I think undermines Moriarty as a villain
and sort of takes away some of what we
loved about him which was that he did
think that far ahead and he was that
much on sharks level and if suddenly he
had a partner who gave him a ton of
insight on Sherlock then well he was
cheating and he wasn't the guy we
thought he was and I don't want the show
to go there and I'm kind of having a
hard time in my head thinking of
anything that they can do that doesn't
involve that sort of thing on some level
now to be fair the writers of the show
are much cleverer than I am so I'm not
saying that there isn't some way to do
it I'm just saying I can't think of it
and I think they also are potentially
gonna have some trouble explaining
motivation for euros besides just sort
of copping to she's psychotic I mean
which I suppose could work but I mean
the fact that Sherlock did not recognize
her and yes I grant she was disguising
her voice she had glasses she probably
had hair that he had never seen her in
before and he was wacked out of his mind
undrugged
but there regardless of that the fact
that he didn't recognize her at the very
least says he probably has not seen her
as an adult he probably had if he has
any memory of her at all it's from
childhood and to take somebody from a
child make them an adult and give them a
believable motivation to be messing with
Sherlock to the degree that she's
messing with Sherlock I don't know it's
really hard to come up with a reasonable
motivation for that that isn't just
she's crazy
because kind of you honestly we got that
a little bit already with Morgan yes
more we already had things he was trying
to accomplish but we this show did his
version of cuz he's God I'm crazy with
him already we don't I don't want to do
that again because again that would well
that would devalue both because it
becomes a retread but we'll see if they
can pull this off as I said within the
confines of the episode The Lying
detective thought it worked
terrific I thought the again the
performance that she gave was terrific I
love the way the reveal is handled I and
I think it is excellently executed but
what it implies that what they may have
to do to explain how we got here those
possibilities make me nervous and I'm
really worried about them sticking the
landing because there's a pretty good
chance that the next episode is gonna be
the last episode of Sherlock we ever get
or at the very least last one we get for
a very long time and yeah they better
not end on another cliffhanger because
everyone they've all said like we don't
know if we can get everyone together to
do any more so they need to wrap up
everything pretty firmly and I thought
going in there we're just gonna have to
wrap up the Moriarty stuff but they're
gonna have to now wrap up that and this
whole thing that they've just introduced
that has big implications and could get
really over complicated really easily so
I am crossing my fingers right now how
this series this series four has been
it's been up and down really didn't like
the six thatcher's really love The Lying
detective so will this one keep the
trend of that second one is it gonna
split the difference and just barely
pull it off is it gonna fall down I
don't know but we will find out when it
airs and I will absolutely be there when
it does so whatever your thoughts on
everything I've just talked about if
you've got a theory on euros and maybe
how this will all work that you want to
share with me
you know what drop something down the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe hit that little
bell down there so you get notifications
check me out on Twitter at council of
geeks give a listen to the council of
geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned